it's a head start i don't run a billion
dollar corporation so i can't possibly
understand the finances that go into it
but i do understand and know the
difficulties of putting a film together
and how much blood sweat and tears goes
into that
[Music]
citizens of the reject nation greg here
john
how are you i'm i'm all right today i'm
decent well you know who's not decent
warner brothers
my
god i know we are late to this uh but we
heard about it right away we had to go
to the prey premiere we got uh randomly
asked to do uh the press line for which
we never get asked to do because we love
that movie so much we said yes and we
were on our way to there so we had to
focus on what we had to do getting back
here really late at night but this has
been a topic of conversation for us
all day and i'm sure you guys have heard
many different reasons as to why this is
happening and we will go into the
reasons i'm going to kind of do this
video in reverse i just want to put my
opinion out there first if you haven't
heard
the batgirl movie is getting shelved
meaning they're not releasing it
anywhere no platform not theaters not
their freaking streaming service
that they set up
which should just be your dumping ground
for movies you don't want to release i
think them not releasing it is
so
stupid the dc universe is the most
whack-a-doodle-doo thing i've seen like
in a while man
just this is just bizarre like it's you
have your problematic leading actor in
the form of ezra miller for the flash
and that's creating a whole bunch of
chaos
like what do we do with this now and
then they have batgirl which had like i
just i feel so terrible terrible for
leslie grace
like to get the dream role of a lifetime
and then bam to be hit with this you got
jk simmons who keeps getting duped left
and right when it comes to this dc
franchise man
like what are they thinking and then you
got a deal in below who had amazing
directors they did bad boys for life
directing episodes of miss marvel
fantastic directors and so you know
there were test screenings a while ago
that said that this was
received so poorly but i'm like that's
what test screenings exist so you can
test it and go what do we need to try to
fix like what do we need to try to make
better what do we need to re-edit do we
need to reshoot some stuff what makes me
upset is there's so many people who work
so hard on this film even if it ended up
being a poor film like if that's the
general consensus there's no one who
could persuade me into thinking that you
know the people involved half-ass their
work into this i'm sure they put their
heart and soul into this film especially
leslie grace it's upsetting to me it
really is upsetting and we're like yeah
it might be a bad film but freaking let
us decide you got a streaming platform
put it on your streaming platform and
you developed it for your streaming
platform specifically it was part of an
initiative to put more content there
it's honestly really really really
annoying that has been the main
conversation that i've had all day with
people in between doing the prey stuff
today was this is just silly like
my god this is silly now you're just
gonna have people
being like i wonder what it was i wish
we could have seen it you know i i
wasn't even that hyped for this film
like and then to hear this i'm like god
damn it release the batgirl movie now
you're gonna have that side rising up
there's such a divided camp when it
comes to the dc universe there are some
trailers that we've seen that just i
know i'm really dominated so i'm sorry
john i just
there's so many things about it it just
are infuriating to me because yeah like
i'm looking forward to black adam
whatever weird dc universe that rocks
apparently building out of dc league of
super pets and black adam i'm looking
forward to that shazam 2 looks great
hell you know i don't say it
the flash looks pretty cool too
all right it does look cool as much as i
really don't like this ezra miller like
that's a good trailer what can i say i'm
sorry it's good trailer well and in the
sad timeline that we live on the flash
movie for all of its various slings and
arrows will probably still come out on
one of these ways to watch it exactly
keaton getting kicked out of two films
now
yeah he's got aquaman and now he's now
this isn't coming out and this has got
to be less controversial of a film
overall which is the ultimate irony just
release it let us not like it we'll move
on right away but their hard work
deserves to be
at the same time i'm like come on maybe
they're proud of it a little bit
brendan frazier was returning for this
crying out loud i mean yeah what john
there's like a couple of reasons that
all seem muddied from what i could
gather from reading the original new
york post exclusive was that yeah it's
what you've heard is oh this movie
tested so poorly that they're like look
we cannot put out a bad batgirl movie we
just have to shelf it and and cut our
losses and move on since then there's
been some updates uh from deadline
especially is where i pulled a lot of
this basically saying that it has little
to do with the quality of the film at
all and actually uh lines up with and
this is
a super paraphrase but basically lines
up with a business opportunity to clear
some of the debts that discovery is
inheriting from their merger with the wb
in axing this and the scoob movie that
they had planned they are theoretically
basically i don't know making their
financial situation better moving
forward and so yeah that's even more
upsetting and according and again this
is even more if that's the truth it's
like what so all these people who
[ __ ] before so much working at this
are now getting axe so you can save some
money yeah and even and not even save
the money like that's the sad thing
about the the society we live in is the
money is spent and they've lost that
money but like 100 million it's more
cost efficient to the bottom line to
just waste that money and all that time
and resources instead of putting it out
for whatever reason and in the deadline
report they even say the film only
tested once and the
reaction wasn't that bad so i don't know
who to believe but it does seem like a
very murky situation and a very sad one
if anything a deal and below are
literally what i think it's a deal is
getting married today or or as this news
has been breaking so i feel terrible for
them too because like on your wedding
day they're a couple no no one of them
is getting married i was like aren't
they brothers
i don't know i don't think they're
related but still what's up they're
getting married and they're both in
attendance because they're both
ostensibly as good of friends as it
appears they are on camera furthermore
in the deadline article they say that
and again you know sources say take it
with a grain of salt but the wb even
wants to or discovery wants to find a
new project for a deal and belong to do
with leslie grace to make up for this
moment
why would they work with them
i don't know
i guess they really didn't like that
plan of dumping you know like mid-budget
to expensive originals on hbo max or
something why would a deal and all work
with these guys hey guys i know you
pulled the plug on you don't do it
i know we cast your careers into a weird
shadow of doubt with our reasoning on
this but this time it'll be great this
is the stupidest thing man it is weird
damn it warner brothers restore the
snyder verse while keeping your main dc
thing going release back girl release
the air cut fire ezra miller but also
release the flash do it all the
background is just going to be release
any cut release
any cut at all release the dailies i
mean yes yeah you got to like factor in
production costs for re-editing and then
also possible reshoots and visual
effects there's things yes there's more
money to be involved to finalize this
project
[ __ ] man
that is so dumb
i don't know this this news is so stupid
of me
it's uh it's a head start
i don't run a billion dollar corporation
so i can't possibly understand the
finances that go into it
but i do understand
and know the difficulties of putting a
film together and how much blood sweat
and tears goes into that so
yeah
this is this is ridiculous to me this is
insane
what do you guys think
subscribe leave a like click that bell
we gotta shout out some pictures john
the float goat seven olivia del guy my
oh my looking dandy andy funk faster
than a ferrari enzo lorenzo baxter
pimply differently sane that's what i
got marco kt tunstall hell with it levit
abdellip
use the force lauren american horse he
got raided because he was simply faded
joanna with the plan of saint louis
rogue cree i bow down to you with my
knees
soul jelly 94 justin martin when are we
starting a youtube channel together
rosie baby i'm just i'm just glad you're
doing better i'm glad you're feeling all
right quit stalling colin
and call me
colin
phillip jambalaya smith jr jen the kylo
ren smith melanie leblanc walk in the
walk jason nolan your balls are growing
touch john trakkus oh i wish you would
tj glad to have you back here buddy bud
thank you guys
so much for being top tier supporters of
the reject nation
the month of july get shout out again
this month to make up for being late see
ya
[Music]
you